oh okay this might actually be nine
point nine nine nine nine nine nine nine
[Laughter]
I face-planted the landmine good job me
ninety-nine point nine blah blah blah
impossible I made it I am the king of
bottle runs I have never been defeated
and no one can say otherwise I don't
care what video evidence you have I'm
the best I'll go on without you little
Jeremy then what do you want for
christmas besides you just nope nope
nope nope nope [ __ ] your things don't
care does it look like I even give one
half of a [ __ ] what you throw at me
don't it even look like I remotely care
how well I'll just hang out here
[Music]
jump I'm gonna make it oh I hope you
enjoyed your snack little kitties
well loosely here goobers don't mind
Santa Claus and all the blood just
regular Ranger stuff
no one's gonna quite fit thank you
breakdance for a little bit here epic
bottle run bro you got it I don't even
need to win let me go alright a paddle
run try those winners without taking any
dabbling things like it'd be pretty easy
not hurt a little kid floating in front
of a wall doesn't leave that bad hello
excuse me sir you seem to hit yourself
with your own axe give me man you seem
to have chopped my nards off that's okay
I didn't want any kids anyway
excuse me sir did you know that guns are
dangerous yeah a permit for that
hello what do you have a permit for that
weapon that does it hello Santa oh I
want to ask you my kid wanted something
for Christmas your dad about something
else since we're here bike fall I beg to
differ
Santa I've never had any problems with
his bike falls ever Santa has had a
problem whoa what the hell happened
can I survive the fall well probably by
blowing by the fence that seemed to have
works out okay really really really
could really could you [ __ ] our poon
down Alma but Alma harms but I seems to
be alright yeah I won oh my ding dong
turned into a [ __ ] spoon alright said
whoa whoa whoa whoa
good job son okay son can you survive
given my track record I'm gonna go with
no but I've never lost a obstacle course
what's so up ow ow ow ow son please take
these arrows out of my back Santa's
Blackheart
oh la cueva I'm guessing that means the
king hello have you seen a Cueva over
here been looking for some Jose oh my
god really
okay this apparently is a Spanish game
here's a god damn test of doom can I go
can I go please break it if you can give
me a chance
test of doom all right just a boom take
two
thanks for I'm just collecting everyone
Oh God what the hell this is absolutely
amazing
I'll write in my balls why okay kid
Timmy you hang on to that pores oh ah
okay this is actually a fun one I'm
actually surprised oh where did the app
tester doom take fourth um I don't know
I didn't far all right
that's both of you down I squished you
right for my ding-dong Oh MD what is
this my head is knocking oh that's okay
not gonna fit no okay oh sorry did that
hurt son better than being dead with
face chopping oh my god oh you just
killed my bun bun bun you killed my son
and my butt but I am okay still alive
okay there how am I still moving forward
how I couldn't do it those thank you
lady I'm Jillian Wow Wow and uh seems to
be dead now that we know what we're up
against we're surely gonna be able to
read this one go go go go go go go go I
don't want to hear any complaining
thank you bad like us No
all right you warden bastard I've had it
up to here with ya I did that with my
brain apparently what the hell I'm
running free because this is a prison
break and I'm starting a riot yeah you
better
did that with my brain too just watch
out good thing you didn't keep magneto
in his chamber well enough go do that
Wow they're being oh wow wow wow wow
whoa hey whoa well I guess I'll never
have kids again hi honey how are you
doing I what what was that honey you
missed them then whoa that's smarted ah
come here honey I'm ready for ya I got
that new implant hello darling excuse me
darling what I am still alive if you
could just remove that harpoon from my
rectum it would be greatly appreciated
how we out to bubbles
the kitties it's fun here in the
lawnmower really really could ease
you can't even good Santa that's one
thing
[Applause]
[Music]